welcome to CES this is our first day
here at maxtech and we are going to show
you guys the top coolest things that we
saw here on day one of course I have to
start out with this killer spear in the
background Las Vegas is known for the
spear and we have a mini budget version
over here now to my eyes it looks
shocking it is just unreal because we're
not used to seeing something like this
of course we have a lot of tech here we
have a lot of display technology but
this is what people are gravitating to
because it just looks magical of course
you can't buy it so let's go ahead and
look at some other tack that you can buy
and next we have this TS Ultra by Verge
it has 1,200 Newton M of power or Torque
and dude this thing is amazing if you
look over here in the back they have
this really new design I have never seen
this before also they have this
California Edition orange is of course
my favorite color this thing looks
amazing it costs way less and the
coolest thing is this thing has over 200
M range for a super bike that is
incredible next we at the jackary booth
and I actually bought a jackary power
pack for my first one and there's tons
of portable battery packs here at CS but
the coolest thing I have seen is this
thing on this Ford Raptor this is
actually a camper which has solar panels
that slide out maximizing the amount of
solar that you can capture so it's
design for camping for overlanding you
guys can see the whole uh tent portion
in the back it makes it really quick
just pop up and you can go to bed
without setting something up so that
cool they have a bunch of different
Electronics you can run you got a
microwave you got a little stove top so
you have everything you really need and
the cool thing is with solar panels they
are a pain to put up I have multiples
you have these flimsy stands but this
thing not only just pop up instantly it
expands giving you a ton of solar that
you can capture compared to just a
little bit trifold um little setup that
gives you very little electricity so
this thing is definitely cool and the
next one is the APR Booth which is
actually our partner for today's CES
video now I actually own two APR robot
vacuums and they've been amazing now
their Booth today is amazing they have a
bunch of entertainment a really cool
setup with a pool here now their main
launches today is the new AIS scuba S1
and the S1 Pro now the S1 has
unparalleled cleaning technology and it
uses these caterpillar uh Treads that
really helps it to get around and be
very mobile it has wave path navigation
technology 2.0 so it's really smart and
all you do is press one button and it
will do all the cleaning for you without
missing anything there are four cleaning
modes for periodic cleaning and they
actually have customizable upgrades so
you can add in a solar panel that will
float and charge it so you don't have to
take it out now the next one is the
scuba S1 Pro this one also has premium
cleaning performance with waveline
technology now what that means is it
will actually go up on the wall of your
pool and Scoot sideways to clean that
line where your water is against the
pool they actually have dual fil filters
in there to make sure the water coming
out is pristine with a big basket and it
has infrared enhancing obstacle
avoidance with sensors now the cool
thing is there's an optional app control
with this little floating Puck not only
does that give it Wi-Fi connection so
you can customize it through the app but
it gives you info about your water
quality if you need to change any
chemicals so definitely go ahead and
check it out go ahead and check out the
links and their pages to get all the
updates with some new other technology
that they released and thank you for APR
for partnering us here at CES now the
next one is this LG Booth right here
this is a transparent display and if you
look at the Quality here it looks
amazing the contrast level is great it's
super bright you guys see the whole
panels moving right here we've seen
transparent TVs before but this takes it
to another level LG is also doing the
wireless HDMI and wireless signals as
well uh so they're really pushing
technology now you might ask why do you
even need a transparent TV well I think
most people do not but imagine if you're
a store owner and you can set one of
these up in your uh as a window
basically and now you could do a bunch
of animations prices um show off new
products and they actually still see
into your store that is something that's
going to grab people's attention and get
people to stop take a look and come on
in now the next one is this insane
scooter Contraption now we've covered a
lot of ebikes people have different
scooters but this thing is actually a
3in in one as you guys see we have this
massive tread on the back and then on
the front we have this ski that you can
attach and that allows you to go in the
snow whatever bad weather you have and
still have a blast now this is it all
specked out if you actually follow this
way through all of their cool scooters
bikes and everything they have this is
actually the same one with the regular
tires on now this thing will actually
hit 30 6 mil an hour so you can fly like
crazy and it's built well but what blew
my mind and the other guys mind here is
that you can buy this with the tread
with the ski and the tires for
$2500 when you look at other options on
the market that are really fast
off-roading scooters they R about that
price but you cannot use them in the
snow in the sand if you keep the front
wheel on and put the treads on so if you
want to Adventure check out this Phantom
one next we're here at the Samsung booth
you guys could see everything is AI you
can get an AI washing machine AI fridge
AI TVs everything's AI even an AI Martha
Stewart if you want to be doing some
cooking here now honestly I think that's
a little bit annoying and obnoxious
because it's not really AI there's smart
algorithms and different stuff that's
happening but I think the coolest thing
here other than all the amazing TVs
micro LED are these new laptops I'll
scoot in here this is Samsung's new book
4 Pro using Intel's new processors that
are a lot better this thing is Slim and
lightweight a great Windows PC now we've
covered the previous ones before these
just got announced and I am very excited
to compare them to the Macbook so if you
guys want to see that make sure that you
subscribe next up we're over here at the
U green booth and they have a ton of new
charging accessories like you can see
right over here this is their first
robot Gan charger this right here is a
30 W and it has this cool design with
these little feet where it stands up you
can see the uh outlet pops out like that
this is a 30 wat charger and the cool
thing about it is when it's done
charging it actually has a little happy
face so you know that it's done and they
actually have a 65 W right here which is
a three
port and a bunch of other accessories we
could actually move over here and over
here they have a variety of different
charges the 45 W 65 W mini we actually
have Max safe ones like this very very
slim Max safe 15w portable charger right
here but I want to show you guys this
300 wat fast charging with 48,000 mahs
built in with this cool little
flashlight so this is perfect for going
camping and charging up all of your
accessories they also have this awesome
little charger where you can actually
put it out like a
stand bam set it down right on your
office desk table and plug in a couple
of other things on the bottom like they
just have such a massive variety of very
high quality fast Gan Chargers so
definitely check them out all right guys
so that was it for day one we saw a
bunch of stuff but just showed you guys
what we are interested in there is so
much more to come so click that Circle
above to subscribe check out the other
video right there and we'll see you in
the next video